let's talk about hatred mail I'll remind
you what hatred mail is if you've never
heard it before take a listen to this
because the government that is
supposedly totally inept is the same
government that can pull off a
conspiracy that'll blow your mind
patriot man written by Patriots who hate
David Pakman because America because
freedom yeah I had sort of a difficult
time selecting a hatred mail this week
because it's been insane the hatreds
have clearly been incredibly emboldened
by what is going on in the national
presidential race I decided on this one
that I'm about to play for you because
it's at least somewhat related to the
election in that it mentions Hillary
Clinton we only have a few weeks left
before this election we're going to have
plenty of time for the non election
related hate mail from people who really
really hate me often for personal
characteristics that I was born with we
will now listen to this week's hey treat
male you are a socialist David Pakman
show don't you realize that lower taxes
means more money to go back into the
private sector buying goods and services
that our makeup bought but you never
produced a thing in your pathetic life
you couldn't keep a tomato plant alive
prick way to support Hillary who is an
elitist and why is David such a ninny
David is a shill for Hillary just like
The Young Turks I thought David was an
economics major what a Jew
I like that thrown in at the end there
it's a critique about my economic views
and my degree and just all sorts of
different stuff and then why not just at
the end what a Jew this David in
addition to all the other stuff yeah I
mean this but I don't know what I've
said that suggests I am a socialist I
paid I that I am in favor of well
regulated capitalism and I don't know
how you could watch the show Pat and
come away thinking this is a socialist
program well I love the idea too that if
you're at all educated in economics then
of course you have to agree with
you have to be conservative sort of
laissez-faire capitalism yeah yeah that
you so economics majors believe
trickle-down is a is a sensible thing I
mean that it just doesn't follow
logically at all but there's not usually
that much logic from a lot of these
hatreds and of course the whole shill
for Hillary thing I don't know what
clips you saw but if you've been paying
attention to our election coverage for I
mean at this point more than a year I
don't know how anyone could do a fair
analysis of the show and say that we
shill for Hillary Clinton we basically
have reluctant but pragmatically did
reluctantly but pragmatically I've
decided that that's who I'm going to be
voting for in November and to say that
that what we're doing is shielding for
Hillary Clinton not really making sense
to me that I did enjoy the insult though
that you couldn't keep a tomato plant
alive yeah that's truly true yeah
oh that's absolutely true I bought
recently I had like an herb garden which
is my friend who's a landscape architect
and as a garden center said this is the
easiest thing to keep alive I mean they
it barely needs water you can put it
indoors just near a window where there's
some Sun half my herbs died so that
allegation for the first time there's
been a very precisely accurate
allegation made in hatred mail that
notwithstanding economic views ur my
views on the election I probably
couldn't keep it tomato plant alive
Warby Parker is offering a free five day
home Tryon to give you the opportunity
to check out their glasses I personally
wear Warby Parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trial dot-com slash TDP s I don't really
like going into glasses stores and
trying on glasses while the salesperson
sort of hovers over me and I like more
than thirty seconds to actually figure
out whether I like the glasses so with
the Warby Parker home Tryon I was able
to pick five pairs that I liked put them
on in the comfort of my own home pick
the one I like the most and then Warby
Parker put my prescription lenses in
there for me a lot of people don't know
that the eyeglass industry is controlled
by just a few big corporations that keep
prices very high like $300 for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need
you can try five pairs and see what you
like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker comm
slash TDP s it costs nothing